So, wo habe ich meine Flasche Wasser hingeschmissen?
Ah, da.
Das Dumme ist, die sind so durchsichtig, die sieht man teilweise nicht.
Übelst random, vor allem wenn sie hinter jeder Menge Mist steht.
So, letztens hat mich doch jemand gefragt, ob beim Black Friday was Gescheites dabei gewesen ist.
Und ich habe gesagt, nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also, nee, bis jetzt nicht, aber ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Ich glaube.
Und dementsprechend dachte ich mir, wir gucken mal zusammen irgendwie die üblichen Verdächtigen an.
Wenn ihr irgendwas Gutes habt, oh nice, weep, weep, Emotes.
Wenn ihr irgendwas Gutes habt, sagt Bescheid, es kommen gute Kopfhörer am Freitag.
Excellent, was denn für welche?
Was hast du dir denn geholt?
Hast du dir gebyt?
Gesniped?
Achso, ach nee, ach nee.
Du, ich habe das falsch gelesen.
Du hoffst, es kommen gute Kopfhörer.
Ich, ich, ich, jetzt hörste mal, ich muss die Nachrichten teilweise, teilweise mal lesen, anstatt einfach nur so eine halbe Sekunde drauf zu gucken.
Ich habe, ich habe, ich habe rausgelesen, du hast die Kopfhörer bestellt, die kommen hoffentlich bis Freitag.
Ja, das ist natürlich die Frage.
Ob da was, es gibt ja meistens ein paar gescheite Sachen.
Ey, ohne Scheiß, mittlerweile ist das so bescheuert, ja.
Erst hatten wir Black Friday.
Dann hatten wir.
Cyber Monday und Black Friday.
Dann hatten wir Black Friday Week und Cyber Monday Week oder was auch immer.
Und dann hatten wir irgendwann Black Friday Monat.
Cyber Monday Monat.
Ich warte noch, dass irgendeiner sagt, Leute, 2024 Black Friday Jahr.
Also, das ist wirklich komplett.
Zumal, ganz ehrlich, bei den meisten Sachen sparst du ja nicht einmal großartig, was?
Du lässt dich hauptsächlich dazu verleiten, Zeug zu kaufen, was du überhaupt nicht brauchst.
Und wenn du es doch brauchst, dann ist es oftmals gar nicht so billig, wie es den Anschein hat.
Gerade bei Amazon sieht es dann immer so geil aus.
60 Prozent billiger.
Guckt man mal irgendwo anders.
Ja, okay, es ist ein bisschen billiger, aber am Ende hat man irgendwie 10 Euro gespart oder sowas.
Also, naja.
Es gibt Prime Days, ja.
Es gibt, da gibt es, die haben doch, die haben so eine Weihnachts-Sale und alles.
Die haben quasi ein Drittel des Jahres gefühlt ist da irgendein super.
Krasser Sale, der jetzt ganz, ganz wichtig und bald ist er vorbei und jetzt musst du unbedingt kaufen, ne.
Und dann musst du in die Gruppe kommen.
Oh, ne, ne, ne, ne, Moment.
Leute, Leute, ich muss das zumachen.
Das kann ich mir heute nicht geben.
Ich muss es schließen.
Zack, zack, zack.
Nicht, nicht, dass ich aus Versehen hier noch.
So, ich wollte Updates machen.
Habe ich schon.
Okay, Reboot.
Ja, ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich habe tatsächlich heute ein bisschen Offstream.
Daran weitergebaut und ich glaube, nächsten Stream können wir tatsächlich mal versuchen.
Ich habe auch schon die ersten, ne, ne, vorne ist ja gar nichts drin.
Ich habe auch schon tatsächlich die allerersten, ich weiß nicht, ob ich die hier schon drinne habe, ne, ich habe schon angefangen mit FFM Pack, also noch nichts wirklich, nur included bisher, die Webcams auszulesen.
Also, da können wir das nächste Mal weitermachen.
So, das kommt alles weg.
Alles weg.
Reboot.
Ja, eher bei Udemy ist es auch so heftig.
Es ist, es ist generell so.
Wenn du mal guckst, guck, guck auch mal, wir bauen heute gar nichts.
Heute, heute nicht, heute nicht.
Heute nochmal Rust, am dritten Tag in Folge Rust, das halte ich geistig, da bist du geistig, drehst du, drehst du durch.
Also, was, was wir gebaut haben, das kann ich dir kurz sagen, beziehungsweise, wo wir noch am Bauen sind, ist, ähm, wir bauen eine Web-RTC,
eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC, eine Web-RTC.
Also, wir benutzen eine Web-RTC-Library in Rust, um in unserer ASP.NET Core-Web-Anwendung Webcams zu streamen in den Browser.
Sowas habe ich schon mal gemacht, damals mit Go und ein bisschen selbst gebastelt noch.
Aber ich dachte mir, wir machen das mal mit einer Rust-Library, da kann man ein bisschen Rust lernen.
Und ich sagte ja, ey, Rust lernen war, glaube ich, keine als gute Idee.
Das ist eine ganz abartige Sprache in manchen Bereichen.
Und sonderlich lesbar auch nicht.
Welche Kameras sind denn gerade gut, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab, also, ich kann nicht sagen, welche ich hab.
Ich hab, ähm, zwei Wisecams mit Custom-Firmware.
Eine im Flur, eine an der Heizung, unten im Keller, dass ich die Thermostate und Druckanzeige ablesen kann.
Und dann hab ich Reolink-China-Chinesen-Dinger, weil die...
Ohne Cloud funktionieren und per RTSP einfach abgerufen werden können.
Aber ansonsten, Black Friday-Jahrzehnt, ja.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt eben gerade sagen?
Ähm, ja, ihr müsst mal gucken, es hat ja alle laufend irgendwas.
Es ist genauso, alle Internet-Anbieter, also alle Provider, haben ja gefühlt auch das ganze Jahr über
irgendeine super krasse Sonderaktion, die läuft jetzt nur noch eine Woche oder läuft einen Monat.
Jetzt läuft sie nur noch eine Woche und dann wurde es, weil es so beliebt war, eine Woche verlängert.
Und es war so beliebt, dass wir noch mal einen Monat obendrauf, die sind so richtige Gönner immer alle.
Und sobald das vorbei ist, kostet es auch nicht mehr, dann ist die nächste Aktion am Start.
Also, im Prinzip ist es Dauer-G-Bait und es zieht halt, ne.
Es zieht und deswegen machen das alle.
Ich finde es auch nicht verwerflich, ist schon okay.
Aber ich finde es immer lächerlich, wenn sie so tun, als gäbe es das alles nur einmal im Jahr.
Was, die haben eine Klingel?
Muss ich mal gucken.
Das Ding da?
Moment, das ist doch diese...
Ey, das ist doch diese Standard-China-Chinesen-Türklingel, die es unter fünf verschiedenen Brands gibt.
Die gleiche habe ich auch hier.
Allerdings von irgendeinem anderen Hersteller, nicht Reolink.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sieht genauso aus.
Shelly, da können wir mal gucken.
Was, was Shelly am Start?
Das ist eine gute Idee, da gucken wir mal kurz rein.
Ja, als PoE ist sehr, sehr praktisch.
Aber bei mir ist das...
Problem, ich kriege PoE nicht so ohne weiteres durch die Wand.
Nee, das ist nicht der Nachfolger von Ring.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Ring noch gibt, aber sowas wäre mir nie ins Haus gekommen.
Shelly, bis zum 27. November.
Leute, soll ich euch mal was erzählen, was extremlich pock ist?
Für solche Momente, warte mal.
Pock.
Emote.
Ich brauche kurz das Pock-Emote.
Pock.
Save Image.
Download.
Wget.
Hallo?
E.
Copy Image Link.
Wget.
Und jetzt wollte ich sagen, Image Cat.
Pock.
So, das brauche ich, weil...
Also, wenn wir Pock nicht auf dem...
Im Terminal haben, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
So.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich vor lauter Pock downloaden.
Und das Schöne ist, wenn man Pock im Terminal hat,
kann man auch noch...
...eine Schleife drum machen und dann hat man unendliche Pocks.
Das ist quasi Vertical Pock Slide.
Richtiges Pogging.
Das Problem ist, ich habe jetzt ganz vergessen, warum ich eigentlich Pock runterladen wollte.
Aber Hauptsache, wir haben massive, massive Pock-Ausgabe im Terminal.
Ja, aber...
Ach so, ja, ich wollte euch was erzählen, was extremlich pock ist.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder.
Und zwar, guck mal hier.
Wenn wir uns den aktuellen Kalender so angucken,
dann stellen wir fest, dass wir in der vorletzten November-Woche sind.
Was sagt euch das, Chat?
Das ist eine rein rhetorische Frage, ihr könnt das nicht wissen.
Das sagt uns, dass ich nur noch...
...dass ich nur noch morgen, übermorgen...
Also, im Prinzip, dass ich nur noch vier Tage arbeiten gehen muss.
Morgen ist den ganzen Tag wieder super agil.
Ich habe ein super agiles Hyper-Agile-Gemiete, da mache ich nichts.
Aber das ist ja so gewollt.
Und dann habe ich noch drei Tage, wo ich wirklich arbeiten muss.
Und dann...
...habe ich für November, für die letzte...
Wobei, das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Hier muss ich...
Hier müsste ich...
Hier müsste ich theoretisch auch noch arbeiten.
Aber, da haben wir so eine komische Veranstaltung, zwei Tage lang.
Die ist nicht in Frankfurt, die ist hier in der Nähe woanders.
Und...
...da fahre ich hin, das ist so quasi meine letzte Amtshandlung dann dieses Jahr.
Und dann ist Urlaubsstelz.
Dann ist quasi von hier...
...bis kompletten Dezember, bis ersten Arbeitstag im Januar...
...der nicht Montag ist.
Moment, leckt das wieder ein bisschen?
Habe ich quasi...
...über einen Monat...
...frei.
Hast du beim Arbeitgeberwechsel keinen Resturlaub nehmen müssen?
Nein, muss ich nicht.
Der neue Arbeitgeber hat gesagt, sie übernehmen das, wenn ich ihnen eine Bescheinigung bringe, wie viel ich schon genommen habe.
Da muss ich auch noch bei der Personalabteilung anrufen, weil die haben irgendwas nicht richtig gebucht.
Aber die haben gesagt, sie machen das.
Und das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Das heißt, ich brauche jetzt 17 Tage für das restliche Jahr.
Und dann habe ich nochmal...
...ja, irgendwie...
...4 oder 5 Tage übrig.
Den kann ich dann noch Anfang nächsten Jahres oder so nehmen.
So sieht es aus.
Pog.
Ja.
Finde ich das.
Gut.
Dann wollen wir nochmal schauen, ob Shelly irgendwas Gescheites am Start hat.
Ach ja.
Hat MyDeals oder so wieder so eine...
...Übersicht für Black Friday?
Die haben doch meistens eine ganz brauchbare...
...Übersicht immer.
Hier, Black Friday Deals.
Das Ganze machen wir allerdings mal auf dort, wo ich einen Dark Theme am Start habe.
Und einen Dark Reader am Start habe.
Okay, gleich.
Viel besser.
Wir können es auch einfach in der VM aufmachen.
Dann hat es wenigstens...
...einen Sinn, dass die VM an ist.
Cancel. Nein.
So.
Gucken wir gleich rein.
Lass uns mal kurz checken, was Shelly hat.
Bei Shelly ist das...
...ist auch nicht alles doll.
Aber gerade diese Unterputz...
...Relays, die finde ich ganz nice.
Da habe ich auch ein paar im Einsatz.
Wobei ich viel mehr noch verbauen wollte.
Seit Jahren schon.
Und habe es nie gemacht.
Ich traue mich da auch nicht richtig ran.
Top Angebote.
Smartes Sicherheits-Bundle.
Shelly Gateway, Shelly Morse.
Ja, super krass. High Security.
Das ist doch auch irgendein Bild aus dem...
...was die AI...
...generiert hat hier, oder?
Shelly Smoke juckt mich.
Shelly Smokes will ich nicht. Die halten...
...angeblich nicht lange.
Habe ich irgendwo mal in einem Review gelesen.
Ja, weil...
...lange Batterie-Lebensdauer.
So, so.
Fünf Jahre mit WiFi-Connection.
Da habe ich schon meine Zweifel, ob das stimmt.
Shelly Smoke.
Aber immer gut.
Ich habe ja...
...Punkrauchmelder brauche ich nicht.
Also die Steckdosen, die finde ich, die taugen nichts.
Die haben gar keine großen Features.
Das ist nur eine Steckdose.
Das ist B und sonst was. Das gefällt mir nicht.
Ich persönlich mag ja auch, wenn die noch...
...einen Schalter haben. Wobei, die haben vielleicht einen Schalter.
Dass man einen ausschalten kann, ohne...
...rein rauszustecken.
Mit was laufen die Shellys? Mit WiFi...
...oder Zigbee? Mit WiFi.
Shelly Dimmer. Brauch man nicht.
Shelly Bloom.
Button?
Ist das ein WiFi-Button, oder?
BLE-Button!
Okay, sowas ist tatsächlich...
...ganz praktisch.
Je nachdem, was man da für...
...Anwendungszwecke für hat. Aber so ein BLE-Button...
...kann man ganz gut verwenden.
Für alle möglichen Dinger. Wenn man halt einfach mal...
...irgendwas braucht.
An der Tür...
...hinhängen zum Draufdrücken und sowas.
Und dann beispielsweise...
...checken lassen, ob alle Fenster zu sind.
Oder mit dem Button...
...das Wohnzimmer in...
...wir wollen jetzt Film gucken...
...versetzen oder was auch immer.
Gibt es zig Varianten.
Wobei...
...also das ist schon mal gut, dass es auf BLE...
...basiert. BLE, das ist quasi Low Energy...
...Bluetooth. Das verbraucht nicht so...
...viel Strom. Ich hab mir...
...vor einer Weile mal so ein Zigbee...
...Akara...
...Xiaomi-China-Chinesen-Multi-Button-Ding...
...gekauft. Mit insgesamt...
...6 Buttons drauf, die man dann alle...
...auch noch unterschiedlich ansteuern kann.
Also, du kannst Single-Click machen...
...Doppel-Click, Triple-Click und Lang-Click.
Also du hast da theoretisch...
...massig Möglichkeiten Sachen zu schalten.
Und eigentlich benutze ich das nur...
...im ersten Stock, um Licht an- und auszumachen.
Aber ist ganz praktisch.
Du hast IOProker am Start.
Was hatte ich denn? Muss ich mal fragen, weil...
...ich hab mit IOProker auch schon so ein bisschen...
...rumgebastelt, aber hab jetzt bisher noch nicht...
...so den, für mich...
...den überzeugenden Punkt...
...gefunden vs. Home Assistant.
Ich hab IOProker hauptsächlich...
...im Einsatz, weil es dafür eins...
...zwei coole Plugins gibt...
...die ich so noch nicht für Home Assistant gefunden hab.
Aber...
...wenn ich den ausschalten würde...
...müßte ich mich auch nicht so sehr stören.
Warum ist es bei dir...
...Home Assistant, äh nicht Home Assistant...
...warum ist es bei dir IOProker?
Was gefällt dir da dran?
Ich will jetzt keinem sagen...
...was er nehmen soll, das interessiert mich nur einfach.
Gibt es eigentlich so PoE...
...all in one?
WLAN, AP, Raumsensor, Rauchmelder...
...keine Ahnung.
Also PoE, WLAN Access Point gibt es aber...
...ob es ein WLAN Access Point...
...mit Raumsensor und Rauchmelder...
...und Bewegungsmelder gibt...
...das wäre cool.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen...
...dass es sowas im Businessbereich auch gibt.
Auf der anderen Seite sind die Geräte...
...vielleicht schlecht zu integrieren.
Wobei ich jetzt nicht wüsste...
...was dagegen sprechen sollte.
Ja, das ist nice.
Aber warum ist jetzt die Wahl auf IOProker gefallen?
Ich meine, das könntest du theoretisch...
...mit jeder Smart Home Lösung machen.
War das einfach das Erstbeste?
Ich meine, man muss nämlich sagen...
...der IOProker ist gerade in Deutschland...
...ziemlich beliebt.
Ich würde einfach interessieren...
...was den Leuten daran gefällt...
...und warum sie es benutzen.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber das wäre dann schlecht.
Hat jemand einen Lichtsensor im Einsatz?
Ich würde gerne checken.
Im Keller das Licht brennen wird oft vergessen.
Ja, habe ich.
Was selbstgebautes.
Aber kein Lichtsensor, der als Lichtsensor...
...verkauft wird, sondern...
...erkenne blinkende LEDs...
...und solche Geschichten.
Das ist aber auch ein Lichtsensor.
Und das ist ganz super easy gelöst.
Und zwar ist es ein...
...ein 20er Pack...
...Photoresistor.
Ja, hier.
10er Pack, 3,50.
Und dann an einem...
...ESP866 dran.
Du kannst dir auch so ein fertiges Board kaufen.
Dann hast du direkt...
...meistens noch so...
...genau sowas hier.
Sowas hier ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Da hast du noch so ein...
...wie nennt sich das Ding auch?
Potentiometer oder sowas.
So ein Ding, wo du die Empfindlichkeit einstellen kannst...
...ab wann es einen digitalen Output gibt.
Also sowas...
...kannst du auch nehmen.
Und dann an jeden x-beliebigen Mikrocontroller.
Und dann siehst du, ob es lichtern ist.
Das ist easy.
Wenn du Bock hast sowas selbst zu bauen...
...kannst du 10 Stück bauen für...
...keine Ahnung, 20€ oder so.
Gibt es aber auch garantiert schon fertig.
100 Pro.
Ja und ich...
...ich habe sowas gebaut zum LEDs auslesen.
Aber wenn ihr LEDs auslesen könnt...
...könnt ihr auch Licht an der Decke auslesen.
Aber das ist natürlich nur für...
...Bastler, die es selbst bauen wollen.
Ansonsten 100 Pro gibt es auch für fertige Sachen.
Weil das immer die Frage ist, was machen wir heute?
Das Ziel ist eine WebRTC...
...Anwendung zu bauen.
Nein, nicht so wirklich.
Nicht so wirklich.
Das ist noch von gestern drin.
Okay, ja.
Wichtig ist, dass es funktioniert...
...und alles unterstützt, was man eben an Hardware hat.
Auratus Nox.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das ist exzellent.
So, also was haben wir sonst noch bei Shelly?
Also den Button, den könnte man benutzen...
...wenn man sonst noch nichts hat.
Wie, das war es schon?
Ach ne, hier unten geht es noch weiter.
Okay.
Shelly Plus 1 Mini.
Die kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Was sind das für welche?
Die sind nochmal extra klein...
...oder wie?
Da ist die Shelly-Seite, backt rum.
Was haben die denn...
...die sind viereckig...
...oder so, in die Richtung, im Vergleich zu den...
...originalen Shellys...
...die, glaube ich, ein bisschen rundlicher...
...waren, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf habe.
Ja, ja, so, was heißt rundlicher?
Wobei, waren die originalen...
...Shellys nicht sogar noch ein bisschen rundlicher?
Ich habe hier...
...HP irgendwo in der Box, welche liegen noch?
Morgen wieder Rust.
Ah, mal gucken.
Ich habe heute aber noch ein bisschen weiter gemacht, auf Github gepusht.
Morgen können wir da ein Video drüber übertragen.
Okay, die sind einfach ein bisschen kleiner.
Input...
...geht nicht...
...mehr mit 12 Volt...
...anscheinend.
Ne, es geht...
...doch, doch, geht, geht.
Es geht...
...bis...
...bis 30 Volt DC...
...das ist ganz gut, dass man damit auch...
...was anderes schalten kann, als nur...
...was aus der Steckdose kommt. Das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Wichtig ist ja da beim...
...Schelly auch, dass er eben damit betrieben...
...werden kann. So...
...ansonsten sind die einfach nur...
...kleiner.
Und...
...der Rest ist, glaube ich...
...gleich.
Okay, wenn man es braucht, ist es nicht verkehrt.
Ah, das ist mir viel zu teuer.
Hauptsache, er ist auf der Hutschiene drauf.
Ansonsten gibt es, glaube ich, nichts...
...Spannendes mehr.
Shelly Uni, da habe ich auch einen hier.
Den finde ich enorm...
...praktisch. Aber den habe ich...
...den habe ich dann doch nicht verwendet. Den finde ich enorm...
...praktisch, weil er eben schon klein ist.
Und trotzdem...
...und sich auch hier mit...
...jedem x-beliebigen...
...Netzteil und quasi jedem Gerät...
...irgendwie anschließen lässt.
Und er ist sogar...
...verhältnismäßig preislich echt in Ordnung.
Darf man in der Mietwohnung einfach...
...Shellys in die Wand schrauben? Ganz ehrlich...
...vermutlich...
...vermutlich schon, solange du nichts...
...kaputt machst und sie im Zweifelsfall wieder...
...entfernst, wenn du rausgehst. Weil das ist ja wieder...
...reversibel quasi mit Shellys.
Vermutlich wird das schlicht und ergreifend...
...gar keiner merken.
Die Frage ist, ob du an der Elektroinstallation...
...rumwurschteln solltest, wenn du keine Ahnung davon hast.
Ist Shelly ein...
...closed Ökosystem? Nein, glücklicherweise...
...nicht. Das ist auch der Grund, warum Shellys...
...eines der Sachen sind, die ich immer empfehle...
...wenn einer Probleme hat, die...
...man damit lösen kann. Und ich selbst...
...da auch welche im Einsatz habe...
...Shelly selbst...
...also es gibt die verschiedensten...
...Möglichkeiten, ja. Wenn du gar keinen Bock auf...
...die Shelly-Firmware hast, dann kannst du...
...das Motor drauf installieren. Musst du aber nicht...
...würde ich mittlerweile auch nicht mehr machen.
Die Shelly-Firmware ist wirklich gut.
Das Gute ist, Shellys...
...lassen sich in Home Assistant und so gut...
...wie jedes Smart Home System integrieren...
...und das brauchst...
...du nicht. Ich glaube sogar, dass Shellys...
...mittlerweile MQTT können.
Da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher...
...das wurde mal angeteasert...
...vor einer Weile...
...ja. Und eine Web-API...
...haben sie auch. Also die sind wirklich nicht schlecht, die Dinger.
Kann ich LEDs direkt...
...abschließen, hab... was?
...blick ich nicht durch.
Also die Shelly-Sachen, das ist kein Smart Home...
...Hub-System...
...wie man sich das vorstellt. Das sind...
...Geräte, die...
...man in ein bestehendes Smart Home System...
...integrieren kann. Also du kannst die Dinger auch...
...standalone mit der App verwenden. Das funktioniert...
...auch gut, wenn du nicht so viele...
...Geräte hast.
Also was du mit dem Shelly machen kannst...
...ist zum Beispiel...
...nehmen wir mal das Ding, was wir eben hatten hier...
...den Klassiker. Shelly plus...
...nimm das Ding mal hier.
Was du damit machen kannst ist folgendes...
...man sieht es ja hier auch. Du kannst...
...die beispielsweise in die Dose...
...machen, wo dein Lichtschalter dran ist...
...und dann...
...schaltest du mit dem Lichtschalter nicht...
...mehr direkt...
...das Licht an der Decke, sondern...
...du schaltest mit dem Lichtschalter den Shelly...
...und der Shelly...
...schaltet dann das Licht an der Decke.
Da denkt man sich jetzt erstmal so...
...wo ist denn da jetzt der Sinn von, wenn ich da ein Gerät...
...dazwischen habe...
...und mit dem Schalter nach wie vor schalten kann.
Das Ding ist...
...du kannst dann nicht...
...nur mit dem Schalter schalten...
...nein, du kannst dann auch...
...über dein Smart Home schalten.
Und dein Schalter an der Wand...
...funktioniert nach wie vor.
Das ist ja einen der...
...aus meiner Sicht einer der Fehler...
...die Leute machen, die anfangen mit Smart Home...
...die sagen dann...
...das erste was ich mache ist...
...smarte Beleuchtung...
...und das nächste was sie machen ist...
...wenn sie aus dem Raum rausgehen...
...drücken sie an den Schalter...
...an der Tür...
...und dann war es das mit smarter Beleuchtung.
Weil smarte Beleuchtung ist nur solange smart...
...wie sie Strom hat.
Also...
...logisch.
Und deswegen ist es oftmals...
...viel sinnvoller...
...weiter den Schalter an der Wand zu verwenden...
...und eine stinknormale Glühbirne...
...oder halt welche Lampe...
...welches Leuchtmittel wie man heutzutage so schön sagt...
...je sonstje verwendet...
...und du kannst damit...
...theoretisch auch das Licht dimmen...
...da brauchst du aber einen anderen Shelly...
...gibt es auch Dimmer...
...und da kannst du nach wie vor mit dem Schalter an der Wand schalten...
...ja...
...also gerade für die Frau...
...oder die Mutter oder die Oma...
...ist das gut, habe ich so...
...öfters jetzt zumindest schon...
...gelesen, dass das gerne...
...ja...
...dass die Mädels da nicht so...
...technikaffin sind, sagen wir es mal so...
...und dass sie halt gerne einen Knopf wollen...
...anstatt sein Handy zu bedienen...
...ist bei mir hier nicht anders...
...ja...
...und deswegen finde ich das gut...
...wenn die Buttons...
...weiter noch funktionieren...
...an der Wand...
...und man zusätzlich an der Decke schalten kann...
...so...
...was man natürlich dann auch noch machen kann ist...
...wenn man jetzt...
...an der Decke dann nicht eine normale...
...Lampe hat, sondern wirklich eine...
...smarte Lampe mit LEDs...
...RGB-Beleuchtung...
...dass man die Farbe ändern kann...
...den Ton vom Licht...
...beziehungsweise auch...
...die Helligkeit...
...dann kann man das nämlich so...
...einschalten, dass der Shelly...
...gar nicht mehr wirklich den Strom...
...ausschaltet an der Decke, sondern...
...dass der Shelly quasi nur noch dieses...
...Lichtschalter wurde gedrückt...
...weiter reicht an dein Smart Home Hub...
...und der dann quasi...
...über Wifi die Lampe...
...ein- und ausschaltet, aber es geht nach wie vor...
...mit dem Lichtschalter an der Wand...
...und das ist sehr praktisch, also da sind dann da...
...quasi der Freiheit keine Grenzen...
...gesetzt, was man machen kann...
...ja, richtig...
...und das nächste ist...
...vielleicht braucht ihr gar keine smarten...
...RGB-LED-Lampen...
...weil die meisten Leute wollen ja gar nichts...
...mit den Lampen großartig machen...
...die sie über die App ein- und ausschalten können...
...oder übers Handy ein- und ausschalten können, so nach dem Motto...
...ah, ich sitz grad vorm Fernseher, habe in der Küche...
...das Licht angelassen, ich will es von da ausschalten können...
...kannst du mit so einem Shelly ganz ohne...
...Probleme machen, mit einer klassischen...
...kannst du einfach die klassische Lampe drin lassen...
...und...
...der nächste Step...
...was die Leute wollen ist...
...dimmbare Lampen...
...den nächsten Step, den die Leute...
...wollen ist dimmbar und...
...Farbton und nur ganz...
...wenige Leute wollen wirklich...
...RGB, das ist ja auch so ein Ding...
...das habe ich schon hundert mal gesagt...
...es...
...wenn ich das dann auch teilweise auf Reddit...
...oder in irgendwelchen Foren sehe oder hier auch teilweise...
...im...
...im Stream, wenn die Leute anfangen...
...hier, ich mach mir jetzt überall...
...RGB hin...
...die meisten Stellen im Haus...
...brauchen kein RGB...
...die brauchen Remote ein- und...
...ausschaltbar, die brauchen vielleicht...
...dimmbar, die brauchen vielleicht...
...Farbton...
...weiß...
...wie heißt das...
...Temperatur...
...Einstellmöglichkeiten...
...aber die brauchen kein komplettes RGB...
...komplettes RGB ist meistens ultra teuer...
...und du benutzt es eh nicht...
...an manchen...
...Stellen macht es Sinn, dort wo es Sinn macht...
...kann man es machen, bei den meisten anderen Lampen...
...voll und ganz so gut...
...wie es ist...
...ja...
...genau...
...doch, heute ist Black Friday Week...
...im Monat Black Friday, ja, was auch immer...
...wurdest du eine Eton...
...USV 860 Watt...
...für ein Synology...
...NAS verwenden, bei uns fällt bei Spannungsspitzen...
...öfters mal der Strom aus...
...ja und nein, du musst gucken...
...bei USVs, was es für USV-Typen sind...
...und was der Hersteller...
...beziehungsweise ob du dazu was findest...
...ob die USV...
...ich hab's vergessen, wie es heißt...
...ähm, ob die...
...ach, wie hieß denn das...
...ja, genau...
...ob die Hot-Swap-fähig ist, musst du gucken...
...weil, der Trick ist...
...eigentlich interessiert dich Hot-Swap-Fähigkeit...
...nur am Rande...
...was dich allerdings...
...interessiert bei USVs und was die Hersteller...
...oftmals nicht so hinschreiben ist...
...ob die USV weiter funktioniert...
...wenn die Batterie kaputt ist...
...und ja, der reinen Lehre nach...
...hast du sowas wie Online-USVs...
...Online Interactive-USVs...
...bei Online-USVs geht es immer durch die Batterie...
...wenn die Batterie kaputt ist...
...dann...
...geht die Stromversorgung nicht mehr...
...obwohl es quasi noch...
...gar nicht ausgefallen ist...
...aber selbst...
...das sind die meisten, bisschen günstigere nicht...
...aber...
...es gibt beispielsweise normale...
...so relativ günstige USVs...
...die schalten um...
...wenn der Strom ausfällt...
...auf die Batterie, aber...
...wenn die Batterie kaputt ist...
...und der Strom noch weiter geht...
...dann gehen sie einfach aus...
...so...
...ja, ich verstehe den Sinn auch nicht...
...Cyberpower ist so ein Kandidat...
...Cyberpower schaltet...
...zumindest die, die ich mal hier im Einsatz hatte...
...Cyberpower schaltet die Stromversorgung aus...
...wenn die Batterie kaputt ist...
...es ist kein Online-USV...
...ist komplett sinnlos...
...daswegen...
...der Trick um rauszukriegen...
...ob deine USV abkackt...
...wenn die Batterie abkackt ist...
...guck ob du eine USV...
...wir können ja mal gucken...
...welche willst du denn?
...sag mir mal welche du willst...
...da gucken wir mal nach...
...der Trick ist nachzugucken...
...ob die USV...
...hot-swap fähig ist...
...wenn die USV...
...ist gemeint, du kannst die Batterie...
...im laufenden Betrieb rausziehen...
...und eine neue reinmachen...
...wenn die hot-swap fähig ist...
...dann muss die auch...
...einen Batterieausfall verkraften...
...hot-swap...
...und пол der Batterieausfall...
...dann musst du DX-Batterie auspractet werden...
...f sairradet die Batterie ver doet...
...heileнить oder...
...hatt sind dann die Batterie gunnt...
...wenn die app nicht...
...guits die Batterie dargestellt werden...
...ist achieving...
...so bekommst du...
...die spam ich wieder...
...shaft wenn keiner....
...k abstRL schType...
...k munst zu machen...
...ein republic...
Doch, hier, hier stand es doch.
Ich habe eine, Moment.
APC 56
VAMI
BR?
Nee, BR steht da nichts.
Ich glaube,
die hier,
ich bin mir unschlüssig, ob das wirklich
die, die sieht ja auf jeden Fall sehr ähnlich.
Ja, wenn man
gewarnt wird, wenn die Batterie kaputt ist, das finde ich
ja in Ordnung. Aber sie sollte nicht
ausfallen. Den einzigen Ausfall, den ich
über die letzten paar Jahre in meinem Rack hier hatte,
ist, als die Batterie von der USV
kaputt gegangen ist. Nicht der Stromausfall.
Also so ein Ding.
Aber ich habe, ich habe einen Start.
Ich finde die ganz
okay. Wichtig bei USVs
auch immer,
dass sie die Möglichkeit haben, die
Bilderauflösung ist halt voll pepega,
dass sie die Möglichkeit haben, hier USB anzuschließen.
Nee, ich habe sinnlos
gelabert und noch gar nichts gekauft. Wir haben
Shelly Black Friday Angebote. Hier kriegst
du so ein Kabel dabei, AJ45
auf USB, ganz
weird shit. Warum das überhaupt
ein Ding ist, weiß ich nicht. Warum die nicht einfach
einen USB-Anschluss haben, verstehe ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Die könnten den Dinger einfach
einen USB-Anschluss spendieren. Was auch immer. Es ist
so ein AJ45 auf USB
dabei. Die kann man dann,
also das ist quasi ein Management-Port, darüber kann
man dann auslesen, in welchem Zustand
ist die USV und ist die Batterie kaputt
und solche Geschichten. Also sowas,
so einen, den Server runterfahren, wenn die
Batterieleistung nachlässt, also wenn
die Batterie leer wird und
eben Strom immer noch nicht da ist, dann kann man den Server
geordnet runterfahren. Was auch
im Heimbereich das Wichtigste ist, eigentlich für
den USV. Kurz überbrücken und dann runterfahren.
Ja, also das
ist das Teil, was ich am Start habe.
Eher nicht. Tablet, beste.
Hat jemand einen Empfehlung
VPN und Proxy-Service?
Ja, ich hab ne Empfehlung.
Ich hab ne Empfehlung.
Kauf dir
bei, oder hol
dir bei
Digital Ocean
oder Hetzner,
oder sonst wo, ne VM.
Bau ne SSH-Verbindung
darauf auf.
Darauf, auf,
darauf, auf?
Dahin auf?
Deutsch ist schwierig teilweise.
Mit nem Sox-Proxy-Port
und dann stellst du bei dir lokal
dein Firefox oder dein Chrome auf den Sox-Proxy-Port
um. Dann wird dein, geht dein
Browser über die Sox-Verbindung
über SSH und kommt mit der IP vom Server raus.
Mach ich immer so, wenn ich mir
YouTube Premium in Indien kaufen will.
Da muss ich keine
komischen VPN-Service-Dinger abschließen.
Da wird einmal,
wird einmal alle paar Monate
bei Digital Ocean eine VM in Indien
hochgefahren, sich drüber getunnelt,
fünf Minuten später ist es verlängert und die
VM wieder gelöscht hat, hat mich dann 30 Cent gekostet
oder so. Da hast du recht,
daran hab ich noch gar nicht gedacht.
Wie viel kostet das in Indien? Ich glaub 3 oder 4 Euro.
Du, das hält
deutlich länger. So schwachbrüstig
sind die Batterien darauf auch nicht.
Und im Idle brauchen die Batterien auch nicht.
Und deine Server nicht so viel. Also je nachdem, wie viel
du da dran hast. Also das wird auch ein bisschen länger als
zwei Minuten halten. YouTube Premium.
Okay.
Also, jetzt haben wir bei Shelly geguckt.
Ähm, was empfiehlt
denn MyDeals? Die haben doch immer
eine ganz gute zusammen. Little Lunch
Soup Black Week. What?
Nein. Soft...
What the fuck? Kann man das irgendwie sortieren?
Ich würde das gerne... Okay, sortieren.
Wie viel ist das denn?
Wait a minute.
Alter, Alter, das hört... What the fuck?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Okay, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall
sortieren.
Okay, Elektronik,
Gaming, Lebensmittel
und Dings brauchen wir nicht.
Home und Living, okay. Garten, Baumarkt
auch okay.
Telefon, Internetverträge.
Nein. Okay, let's go.
Filde an mit dem...
Deaf Owl. Weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist.
Was?
Die Schmelzbar Black Week.
Ah, Filament.
Ach, jetzt... Okay, jetzt ergibt
der Name auch Sinn. Ich hab's ja nie gehört.
Schmelzbar.
Enelo Basic Ladegerät.
Das war... Also...
Ich will mir keine kaufen,
aber mit diesen Batterien, Leute...
Mit diesen Batterien
hab ich damals, 2011
und 2010,
als ich mit dem Frasier
noch auf der Xbox 360
hier immer Quot gespielt hab,
da hatte ich so einen
Turtle Beach X
ist das Ding, glaube ich,
Headset.
Gibt's eigentlich mittlerweile ein X42?
Ja, die haben gesagt, X41 war richtig gut.
X42 hat gesagt.
Und da hatte ich so einen
Turtle Beach X41 und da
hab ich immer...
Weil ich hab so viel gespielt
am Tag mit dem Fabian zusammen,
dass der immer leer gewesen ist. Da hab ich mir die Akkus
gekauft. War eigentlich eine ganz gute Investition
damals.
Turtle Beach, richtig viel Old Man.
3D Drucker, Laser Cutter
in einem Gerät.
Sportlich!
Aber wenn man eine... Moment, Moment!
3D Drucker, Laser Cutter
und CNC in einem Gerät.
Da hab ich sogar
mal ein Review zugesehen. Das soll, glaube ich, echt
nicht so schlecht sein.
Und es gibt, soweit ich weiß, sogar noch mehr
Aufsätze dafür als diese drei.
Also wenn man so der...
der...
der super hardcore Maker
ist, der...
Sogar irgendwelche Sachen, Laserkatten gravieren und CNC'en möchte daheim.
Dann ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Man muss aber halt sagen, der Kram ist auch nicht billig.
Die Steinl Black Week.
Da gibt es dann Heißluftgebläse.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das sein soll.
Warum nicht?
Wer braucht denn sowas?
Was ist das denn?
So ein Meißelset oder sowas?
GoPro gibt es was.
Sag mal, da ist doch nur Shit dabei gerade.
Kann das sein?
Wir gucken jetzt direkt mal bei Amazon.
Wir machen mal schnell den Kram weg.
Also, komm hierher.
Zack.
Alle Kategorien, alles weg.
Wir wollen nur Elektronik.
Sonst wird es zu viel.
Jetzt ist es, glaube ich, übersichtlicher.
Ey, das hört ja gar nicht auf.
What the fuck, man?
Okay, im Schnelldurchflug.
Alles uninteressant.
Okay, keck, wait.
Ich habe noch keine richtig...
...guten Deals gefunden.
Ich auch nicht.
Und ich glaube auch, dass der Titel dieses Jahr Programm ist,
dass es wieder halt einfach nur G-Bait gibt.
So, die übliche Masche von Amazon.
Ey, bei uns 60% billiger.
Und dann guckst du nach und stellst halt fest,
okay, es ist eigentlich nur 5 Euro billiger.
Oh, guck mal.
Radlerhosen.
So viel reduziert sehen die jetzt gar nicht aus.
Geizhals?
Oder können wir mal gucken, Kleine?
Ich muss gerade mal Chat gucken.
Geizhals.
Black, zu den Black Friday Week.
Okay, vielleicht ist die Geiz...
81 Seiten, ja, ist klar, man.
Okay, Uciko fragt.
Kann mir jemand hier helfen?
Ich habe einen Nagios-Kurs.
Oh, nice.
Dass noch jemand Nagios neu macht in 2023,
freut mich irgendwie.
Ich hätte zwar keinen großartigen Bock drauf,
aber ich habe noch mehr Nagios 2023.
Vom Scratch noch einzurichten.
Aber ich habe es schon oft gesagt,
und ich sage es auch wieder,
Nagios hat immer noch so ein Spot bei mir im Herz.
Ich mag Nagios.
Okay.
Ich habe einen Nagios-Curs aufgesetzt
und einen Postfix zur Alarmierung.
Allerdings bekomme ich alle drei Spiele nur eine E-Mail,
dass ein Host zum Beispiel da ist.
Ich benötige die aber nur einmal
und nicht die drei Spiele.
Ich habe schon die ganze Konfig-Files durch.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht,
das ist zu lang her.
Letztes Mal Nagios habe ich gemacht 2013 oder so.
Nee, nee, nee.
Länger her.
2010 oder so was.
2010, 2011.
2011 war vielleicht das letzte Mal Nagios gemacht.
Das kann ich dir leider aus dem Kopf nicht sagen,
was es da mit Notification-Einstellungen
bei Nagios auf sich hat.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist zu lang her.
Das ist bei Nagios nicht aus.
Notification-Intervall oder sowas.
Und wie es bei Nagios Core ist...
Ich glaube mit Nagios kennt sich heutzutage kaum noch einer aus.
Die coolen Leute verwenden auch keinen Nagios mehr.
Aber ich mag Nagios.
Es gibt ja zig.
Na, Checkmk war Checkmk nicht auch mal ein Nagios Fork?
Die coolen Leute heutzutage verwenden Prometheus
für fast alles.
Wobei man auch ehrlich sagen muss,
Prometheus ist pauschal auch nicht.
auch nicht für alles gut das ist wieder so ein typischer fall von nur weil es
alle verwenden ist es nicht automatisch gut für alles weil für so diese
typischen host up down checks ist prometo ist gar nicht mal so geil
kannst du damit auch machen aber man merkt dass es nicht dafür gebaut wurde
zabbix ist auch so ein ding was ich prinzipiell ganz nice finde das doofe an
zabbix ist dass das web interface und die konfiguration so ultra kryptisch ist
ganz ehrlich ich habe lieber früher nagios templates und konfiguration von
hand in der textdatei editiert und und erstellt als diese undurchsichtige
weirdchampige nagios config da im web interface äh nicht nagios zabbix config im
web interface zusammen zu klicken habe ich nicht keine ahnung selbst der
blacktop
box explorer alleine reicht nicht brauchst noch ein alert manager oder
irgendwas wo du alerts drüber verschicken kannst und du willst ja
vielleicht auch mal ein history haben wie denn die verfügbarkeit deiner host
ist und so was du kannst also mit prometheus musst du dein
monitoring mehr oder weniger selbst bauen
das einzig coole wofür prometheus out of the box ganz gut geeignet ist es halt
für metriken ist ja letztendlich auch eine time series datenbank hauptsächlich
für metriken entwickelt da haust nämlich einfach noch grafana obendrauf und
gut ist aber wenn unser sachen machen möchtest wie host ist ab und down allein
schon die config von den blackbox exportern wie die seine house listen
da rein kriegst ist wirklich dann brauchst du noch notifications und du
möchtest ja vielleicht auch irgendwie so ein verfügbarkeit report haben unsere
systeme waren 99,9 da musst du dir da musst du dir sehr viel selbst
zusammen stricken bei prometheus meinung zu check mk ich konnte da vor
einem Jahr noch gar nichts dazu sagen, aber
nachdem wir auf der neuen,
also auf meiner neuen Arbeit, wird
relativ viel Checker MK benutzt. Ich muss ehrlich
sagen, super
intuitiv ist das Webinterface auch
nicht. Also man sieht, dass es die letzten 10 Jahre
über gewachsen ist und keiner so wirklich
sich Mühe gibt, wo was hin soll.
Also es ist super
weird, wo du teilweise was findest in den
800 Untermenüs.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, Monitoring
gibt es nix, was ich so richtig
uneingeschränkt empfehlen kann.
Ich persönlich fände
Zabbix ziemlich nice.
Hätte Zabbix ein besseres Webinterface und wäre
nicht so weird und wäre es
ein bisschen moderner.
Einfach. Also das finde ich
gut. Ach ja, das
ist Utsiko. Das könnte man dir wahrscheinlich
wirklich ans Herz legen, wenn du
einfach nur checken willst, ob
die VM ab oder down ist. Dann
könntest du wirklich das hier verwenden.
Das ist
wirklich ganz gut.
Das hatte ich auch mal bei mir.
Also so heißt das hier. Guck mal
auf GitHub.
Ist auch recht beliebt,
wie man hier sieht. 40.900
Sterne.
Simpler kann es nicht werden.
Simpler kann es
nicht werden. Guck, Demo-Server.
Aber da hast du halt keine gescheite History.
Da kannst du Up und Down checken und
Notifications.
Und das war's.
Ersteller benutzt dein Konto.
Admin. Kommt ihr jetzt auch
da raus dann?
Ja, das kann man auch machen.
Also das ist wirklich nicht
verkehrt. Wenn du reine
Up ist Down und einfache TCP-Checks
haben willst. Du hast dann aber halt keine History.
So nach dem Motto, wie war meine
Uptime vor drei Monaten oder sowas.
Es gibt einfach kein für mich
rundum empfehlenswertes Monitoring-Tool.
Ich hab's noch nicht gefunden.
Wie gesagt,
Zabbix fände ich nice, wenn es insgesamt ein bisschen moderner
wäre.
Für Metriken finde ich
Prometheus ist eine tolle Geschichte, aber es gibt
kein...
Kennst du ULS?
Ne.
Kenn ich nicht.
Zeig mal.
Das sieht oldschool aus.
Das sieht enorm
oldschool aus.
Das sieht aus wie von 1995.
Okay, zuletzt
Updated 2018, ja.
Also ich weiß nicht, was man damit
macht, aber es sieht alt aus.
Ne, das ist eine
Lebensaufgabe, sowas zu programmieren.
Naja, also es gibt
wirklich nichts, was ich großartig empfehlen kann.
Uptime Kuma ist noch das nicest
von allen für
ein bisschen
Homelab-mäßig. Leider hat Uptime Kuma mir
ein bisschen zu wenig Features. Ich würde
nämlich zum Beispiel auch gerne meine Disk-Usage
überwachen von
einem System, aber das kann Uptime
Kuma nicht.
Also insofern,
ich habe bei mir aktuell einen Zabbix laufen.
Ich hasse den Zabbix aber.
Ey, ich habe mir MW3
nicht gekauft. Achso, Black Ops Gameplay.
Ey, die Xbox
360 steht hier noch.
Ja, Moment. Was ich
programmiert habe, war ein Prometheus-fähiges
ähm, ne nicht Prometheus, ein
äh, doch
Prometheus-fähigen
Domain, wann die Domain abläuft.
Agent quasi.
Aber das habe ich auch nicht
fertig gemacht, wie so vieles. So.
Einmal so ultra-mega-Sidetrack
HD, XD, HD
360.
Wir gucken jetzt mal
bei Amazon. Ne, bei Geizhals
mal gucken. So rum.
Hab ich hier aufgemacht.
Was sagt Geizhals denn?
Was ist denn zu empfehlen? Kann man das irgendwie
ordentlich mal sortieren?
Weil
irgendwie ist 81
Seiten mir ein Tick zu viel.
Äh, Hardware.
Hardware ist schon mal gut. Was haben die denn
für Kategorien?
Hardware, Telefon.
Da sieht man auch, dass es Geizhals
schon eine Weile gibt.
Achso.
Ja, sowas meinen die. Ich hab
bei Telefon eher gedacht, so an Oldschool-Sachen
jetzt. Nicht an Smartphones.
Oh, was ist das?
Festnetz-Telefone.
Unbedingt.
Das brauche ich. Ein Gigaset-Tucho.
Ich muss jetzt mal was
Nettes über Geizhals sagen.
Und zwar, die Webseite.
Die hat sich ja die letzten Jahre über
nicht sonderlich viel verändert.
Die sieht mit ein paar Anpassungen
sieht die mehr oder weniger
seit den letzten 10 Jahren plus so aus.
Aber mir gefällt
die Geizhals-Webseite,
weil
das wirkt für mich einfach
wie noch eine Webseite, die man eben
auf dem Desktop anzeigen möchte.
Und die ist auch schnell.
Und die funzt einfach.
Ich mag die Geiz, die Geiz.
Guck mal, wie zackig, wie krass schnell
die Geizhals-Webseite ist, weil es halt einfach
ziemlich plain HTML ist.
Also ich finde die gut.
Weil sie in irgendeine Kategorie
rein muss.
Kennst du die Fortbildungs- und Technik- und Vertriebsinfo...
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht, was...
Wer das anbietet, was das ist, was...
Keine Ahnung.
Die besten Deals, machen wir mal auf.
Hardware und ansonsten
gibt's ja hier...
Hier nix Spannendes.
Ich würd's gerne noch ein bisschen
weiter eingrenzen.
Systeme.
Achso, ja, okay.
Ne, brauchen wir nicht.
So, also ein Platinen-Computer.
Ach, guck mal!
Raspberry Pi 3! Wollen sie die ollen
Dinger loswerden, oder wie?
Es ist wieder verfügbar, ist aber
nicht gerade günstig. Wobei das auch das
8-Gig-Modell ist. Aber es trotzdem, ja.
Hat das 8-Gig-Modell
zum Releasing 64 Euro gekostet?
65 Euro?
Was hat Heise und Geiz halt so miteinander zu tun?
Du bist auf der Suche
nach einem Thermometer mit
Protokollfunktion.
Du meinst so einen Fieber-Thermometer,
wo du da eine History hast?
Also du steckst dir das in Bobbes Mist und das machst
du eine Woche lang und dann kannst du auf dem
Gerät nachgucken,
was du zuletzt hattest an Temperatur,
oder was?
Oder was für ein Thermometer? Oder meinst du ein Thermometer,
was man an die Wand hängt und... Achso!
Achso, ich dachte,
hier...
Thermometer...
Also du meinst ein...
Du meinst ein...
Kein Thermostat, ein Thermometer, ja.
Ach echt? Ist das so?
Ich kann dir einen Thermometer empfehlen.
Wenn du ein bisschen basteln willst,
kann ich dir das beste Thermometer ever empfehlen.
Und zwar...
AliExpress.
Aber nur, wenn du ein bisschen basteln willst.
Also das Ding mit History ist...
Das Ding mit History ist...
Das Thermometer selbst,
mit History ist doof.
Besser, du integrierst das gleich in dein Smart Home ordentlich.
Und wenn du noch kein Smart Home hast,
ist das die beste Gelegenheit,
damit anzufangen.
Oh, AliExpress, please.
AliExpress, man! Wie mach ich den Scheiß zu?
Nicht zulassen, so.
So.
Die Dinger sind echt zu empfehlen.
Die kriegst du teilweise auch relativ günstig.
Muss man immer mal gucken.
Man kriegt die teilweise...
Wenn man mal schaut,
3 Euro für teilweise 3 Euro das Stück.
Oder 3,50 das Stück.
Wenn man hier einen guten Deal irgendwo bei AliExpress...
Das erscheint mir tatsächlich ein bisschen teuer.
Zumindest...
Guck mal, hier gibt es 8 für 40.
40 durch 8.
5 Euro sind wir schon mal.
5 Euro pro Dings.
Also, die Dinger kaufst du dir.
Dann brauchst du...
Irgendeinen Rechner, der Bluetooth hat.
Und dann gehst du auf GitHub
und suchst dir einen der Firmwares raus.
Dafür.
Die ist nicht mehr so ganz aktuell.
Ich glaube, das hier ist die aktuellere.
Und dann flashst du das Ding
über Bluetooth mit Custom Firmware.
Und danach ist das das beste Thermometer,
was es gibt.
Du musst hingehen und stellst...
Also, du kriegst auch noch mehr Funktionen,
als das von Haus aus hat.
Du musst auf jeden Fall
den Intervall runterstellen,
wie oft es intern die Sensoren abfragt.
Und wie oft es per Bluetooth
die Sachen abfragt.
Und wie oft es per Bluetooth die Sachen abfragt.
Und wie oft es per Bluetooth die Sachen rausschickt
ins Netzwerk.
Also, sprich, wie oft es announced
über Bluetooth, was für eine Temperatur das ist.
Also, ich hatte das jetzt im Einsatz.
Ich hatte das jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre,
fast drei Jahre im Einsatz.
Und jetzt ist zum ersten Mal die Batterie leer.
Ich hab's aber auch runtergestellt
auf alle zwölf Minuten oder so verschicken.
Aber das reicht ja.
Ich brauch es ja nicht halbminütlich,
meine Temperatur im Bad zum Beispiel.
Zwölf Minuten, gut ist.
Oder man kann's auch runterstellen
und wie gesagt,
fast drei Jahre hat die Batterie gehalten.
Das ist so eine ganz normale CR2302?
2032?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
So eine ganz normale Knopfzelle.
Und das hat keine History standardmäßig.
Aber das ist preis-leistungsmäßig
super günstig.
Mega nice Funktion.
Mit Custom-Firma.
Mit Custom-Firma kann das auch die Uhrzeit anzeigen.
Und den Batteriestand anzeigen und noch ein bisschen mehr.
Wobei die Uhrzeit relativ schnell auch durch Sync geht.
Das würde ich da gar nicht für benutzen.
Und dann muss das halt so sein,
dass man halt irgendwo hinschicken und wo die History protokolliert wird.
Ich hab's bei mir in Home Assistant drin,
aber du kannst mit jeder x-beliebigen Smart Home Lösung machen.
Hat keine Hardware-Glock.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Deswegen muss das irgendwie mit Clock-Cycle von der CPU gemacht werden.
Man kann wohl irgendwie so ein Sync-Signal über Bluetooth schicken ab und zu.
Aber naja, es ist nicht wirklich notwendig,
dass das Ding die Uhrzeit anzeigt.
Ja, also das kann ich empfehlen.
Bestes, bestes Thermometer habe ich auch im Ganzen ausverteilt.
Nasssysteme.
Das ist doch, da ist doch leer, da ist doch gar nichts drin.
Ich dachte, das ist ein 19-Zoll-Rack.
Dabei ist das so ein hochkantiges Ding.
Das hat man bloß nicht gesehen.
Lul.
Okay, Hardware.
Was, was hier sind hier die besten Deals?
Also ich brauche weder Grafikkarten noch Komplettrechner.
Taugen, Razer, Mäuse immer noch.
Ich will mir keine kaufen.
Und ich frage, ich frage nur, weil ich vor Jahren weg von Razer bin.
Ich hatte, ich hatte jahrelang nur Razer.
Ich war quasi, ich war quasi ein Original-Razer-Kunde.
Ich hatte damals sogar einen Razer.
Kennt das Ding noch einer?
Guck mal, sogar Linus Tech-Tipps hat er was.
Kennt noch einer die, die aller, allererste Gaming-Maus,
die es je gegeben hat?
Mit Ball?
Das war noch mit Ball drinne.
Ja.
Die zeigen es leider nicht.
Von unten.
Ja, hier.
Da war noch ein Ball drin.
Und seitdem, seitdem habe ich eigentlich nur Razer-Mäuse gekauft.
Bis, irgendwann, ich mir eine Razer DeathAdder gekauft habe.
Und die ein Problem hatte, nach einer Woche oder so, dass wenn man die, die, wenn man die rechte Maustaste gedrückt hat, ging das Mausrad nicht mehr zu scrollen.
Weil sie die Tasten reingedrückt haben in das Ball.
Das Mausrad.
Dann habe ich die austauschen lassen und dann hat es die wieder, dann hat es das wieder gehabt.
Und ich habe es nicht eingesehen, eine Maus zu haben, wo das Mausrad nicht geht, während ich die Maustaste gedrückt habe.
Und seitdem habe ich nie wieder Razer gekauft.
Dann hatte ich eine, eine, eine Weile Zoe.
Ist es Zoe EC2A?
So, Zoe-Mäuse hatte ich eine Weile.
Und mittlerweile bin ich seit einer ganzen, einer ganzen Weile wieder bei Logitech hängen geblieben.
Aktuell habe ich eine Logitech Pro Wireless mit so einem Auflade-Pad, dass die Maus automatisch Wireless auflädt, wenn sie draufsteht.
Den Headshot-Controller, nein, den meine ich nicht.
Dazu müsste ich erst irgendwas haben, was mir einfällt.
Das ist eine gute Idee, das ist eine wirklich gute Idee.
Da müsste ich mal kreativ sein, weil ich habe in letzter Zeit wenig gebastelt.
Und deswegen fällt mir das nicht so viel.
Das ist eine gute Idee, schreibe ich mir auf.
Noted, Noted.
Was? Rapu-Mäuse, was?
Was ist das?
Was, was, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Rapu oder Rapo?
Bestimmt China-Chinesen-Zeug, oder?
Achso, das Amazon Basic-Mäuse.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Wir haben ja nicht, wir haben ja nicht viel auf die Reihe gekriegt heute.
Das Ding ist auch nicht totzutun.
Das Ding ist auch nicht totzukriegen, oder?
Die gibt es auch seit 100 Jahren schon, die SSD.
Und jeder hatte schon mal eine gehabt, glaube ich.
Bei Mediamarkt auf Ebay.
Oder auf Ebay von Mediamarkt, je nachdem.
Ja, das hier durchzuscrollen lohnt sich nicht.
Komm, wir schauen mal bei Amazon.
Wir filtern auf Black Friday und sagen jetzt mal Smart Home.
Gucken, was es da gibt.
Da finde ich, gibt es oftmals die besten Deals.
Gerade, wenn man was findet, was krasse und firmwareflashbar ist.
Oder irgendwas, was sich gut integrieren lässt.
Wollen wir mal schnell durch, schnell durchlaufen.
Wir müssen uns nämlich nicht wieder das gleiche angucken, wie das letzte Mal.
Das letzte Mal war nur Schrott dabei.
Deswegen, hier.
Die GNCC WLAN-Steckdose.
Die gibt es auch von 100 Herstellern.
So ein typisches China-Chinesen-Ding.
Gibt es auch von 100 Herstellern.
Die Frage ist...
By the way, kein Photoshop-Bild.
Legit, legit so gewesen hier.
Ähm, ist es mit USB oder ohne USB?
Ist es mit USB oder ohne USB?
Wenn die ohne USB sind, dann sind es sogar noch die schlechten.
G-Home.
Das sind die mit USB, aber ohne Schalter?
Oder haben die den Schalter?
Wichtig bei solchen Dingern immer.
Ob flashbar oder nicht.
Die meisten Geräte, leider nicht mehr flashbar.
Kann man sich das Motor flashen?
Nein.
Sätge.
Sätsch.
Also, ich habe seit einer ganzen Weile...
China-Steckdosen und China-Steckdosen-Leisten im Einsatz mit geflashter Firmware.
Bis jetzt eigentlich kein Problem.
Was sagst du dazu?
Traue ich mich das aufzumachen?
Oh, diese Sorte mag ich nicht.
Oh, die sehen super billig aus, Mann.
Die sehen ja mal auf dem Bild schon...
Also, die sehen auf dem Bild aus...
Wie...
Wie als hätte da irgendein Baby so Alete reingekotzt oder so.
...So, irgendwie Karottenprall reingekotzt oder so...
So sieht das aus.
Aber es sieht auf jeden Fall billig aus.
Es sieht richtig billig aus.
Also, ich glaube...
Also, ich glaube... eher nicht.
Und zumal man die nicht flashen kann.
Zumal man die nicht flashen kann, bist du auf die...
Warent, das ist Zigbee!
Wait a minute!
Also, mit Zigbee...
Könnte das evtl. noch ganz brauchbar sein.
Aber ich finde, die sehen wirklich billig aus.
Mit dem Plastik und diesem Halbdurchsicht.
Guckt mal, wie kacke der Knopf oben aussieht.
Also die sehen auch für meinen Geschmack schon zu billig aus.
Sieht aus wie aus dem Happy Meal.
Ja, genau.
Find sogar ich zu happy.
Find sogar ich zu, sieht zu billig aus.
2 Terabyte für 99 Euro.
Das geht tatsächlich ganz klar.
Hab vor zwei Tagen geguckt, ob ich könnte sein Dual Note Xeon PC...
Oh, 6...
Ist das eine Netzwerkkarte?
Connect X klingt nach 40 Gig?
Oder was für eine ist denn das?
400 Gig!
Ja, das ist enorm wichtig, Leute.
Im Heimbereich würde ich auch sagen.
Also 400 Gig...
Moment, das ist das Falsche, wo ich gucke.
Das ist das Falsche.
Das ist mit Infinity Band oder wie das heißt.
Das ist was anderes.
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein wenig Overkill, oder?
Besser Schisser, aber warum nicht?
Was machst du, dass du so krasses Netzwerkkram...
Ich komme mir super Elite vor mit meinem 10 Gig Netzwerk daheim schon.
Aber jeder, was er so braucht daheim, ne?
Was würdest du benutzen, um eine Webseite zu machen, die ständig Live-Updates macht,
aber trotzdem performant ist und gut aussieht?
Ob die performant ist und gut aussieht?
Das ist ja...
Also ob die gut aussieht, hängt von deinen...
Nein, sehr, sehr Skills ab.
Da kann man dir nicht helfen.
Ansonsten, ich würde alles prinzipiell zur Zeit mit Svelte machen, weil mir Svelte am besten gefällt.
Aber eine reine Webseite reicht dir ja nicht.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall Backend-Sachen, um Server-Updown checken zu können.
Webseite alleine reicht dafür nicht aus.
Ich finde auch, dass SSD-Preise die letzten Jahre über schon ganz okay geworden sind.
Bis auf ein paar Ausreißer immer, wenn gerade irgendwo in irgendeiner Fabrik vollgelaufen ist mit Wasser.
Ja, aber das ist was anderes.
Okay, richtig High-IQ-Shit hier am Start.
Packet Processing Software für Cloud Data Plane.
Also ich habe die einzelnen Wörter verstanden.
Was du machst, habe ich nicht kapiert.
Ja, also alles ist das Schrott, solange es nicht flashbar ist.
Und diese Namen, gell?
Was ist mit den China-Chinesen los?
Woher kommen diese Produktnamen immer?
Ich erkenne sofort, dass das China-Chinesen-Produktnamen sind.
Antela.
GNCC.
Govi, wobei, die hat man, glaube ich, schon, die hat man schon mal angehört.
Atree.
Refors.
Das sind so, Fithop.
Das sind die, das sind typische, Meros auch, wobei das einer von den größeren ist.
So typische China-Chinesen, alles die gleichen Produkten, nur ein bisschen anders gelabelt Sachen.
Meistens irgendwie über Tuya Cloud mit billigen Drecks-Apps, die keiner verwenden will.
Kommt mir nicht ins Haus, äh.
Das, das Dumme ist, dass das Motor bei vielen Geräten nicht mehr geht.
Und das Problem, warum das Motor nicht mehr geht, ist tiefgreifender, als man denkt.
In der Zeit lang konnte man die Geräte noch aufmachen, an die Pins ein Serial Flasher dran löten und flashen.
Das Problem mittlerweile ist, dass die neuen Geräte-Generationen oftmals kein ESP-866 oder ESP-866 haben.
Oder ESP-32 überhaupt mehr drauf haben.
Das ist halt echt doof, ne.
Das wird teuer, wenn ich das anklicke, das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Äh, wobei.
4 Terabyte, 219 Euro, finde ich, geht voll klar.
Würdet ihr die noch kaufen, Chat, nachdem was Golem und Heise dazu geschrieben haben?
Ey, so eine hab ich!
Ich hab so eine!
Was war damit?
Was war damit, Chatge?
Hat die da?
Wartenverlust oder, oder was ist damit?
Hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ich hab so, ich hab so eine hier.
Die haben anscheinend richtige Firma-Probleme.
Äußert sich wie?
Die sterben alle aus, schlecht.
Schlechte Lötstellen soll SSDs von Sanis und WD sterben lassen.
Okay.
Das ist mies.
Ich hab hier nämlich welche, also, was weiß ich, sogar zwei Stück.
Tja.
F.
PS5 im Sale?
Wann kam die PS5 raus?
Ist ja ein bisschen älter.
Okay.
Drei Jahre.
Da würde ich sagen, kommt jetzt nicht direkt die nächste Konsolengeneration.
Aber ich bin eh komplett abgehängt, was das angeht.
Letzte Konsolengeneration, wo ich richtig, richtig viel Konsole gespielt hab,
war Xbox 360 und PS3.
Xbox One und PS4 hab ich mir auch gekauft, direkt zur Release.
War mega enttäuscht und bin dann wieder auf hauptsächlich PC Gaming umgestiegen.
Und seitdem PC-Stells, PC-Master-Race-Time.
Ja, aber nicht schneller, sondern, oder?
Sondern einfach nur kleiner, leiser, was auch immer.
Dieses Zwischenrelease bei der PS4, finde ich, war eines der blödesten Ideen, die sie seit langem hatten.
Schon was gekauft? Ne, auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel geguckt.
Was empfiehlt mir denn Amazon heute?
Wir waren jetzt schon bei AliExpress, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
War das nicht diese AirTag-Alternative, die nicht richtig funktioniert hat, weil es zu wenig Leute benutzen?
Okay, Amazon-Geräte lohnen sich eigentlich immer, wenn man das Amazon-Ökosystem mag.
Ich muss mal gucken. Boah, mein Auge.
What the? Alter, Browser, please.
Krieg dich ein.
Ja, Moment, die Details, die ich...
Ich hatte auch mal welche früher.
Die hatten aber so einen Button.
Da konnte man sein Handy dann damit suchen und sowas.
Und so eher für Presence-Detection.
Weniger für...
Ich mach's an mein Fahrrad und find's wieder.
Amazon geht bei den Fire-Geräten von Android.
Och, wirklich? Das ist aber doof.
Da kann man die Dinger ja gar nicht mal für irgendwas gebrauchen.
Weil das Einzige, wie die Dinger zu gebrauchen waren,
waren mit Custom-Fuels.
Wir haben ja nur das Home-Volumen,
alles, was schon gebraucht wurde.
Oder Superkass, die bloatet,
und alles ausgeschaltet,
und zusätzliche Sachen sideloaded,
was Amazon nicht wollte.
Ja, dann ist es auch...
Es ist wirklich nervig,
wie sehr man bei dieser ganzen Smart-Home-Sache up-to-date sein muss,
dass wenn dir mal ein Gerät verreckt,
du irgendwie gleichwertigen Ersatz noch zwei Jahre später bekommst.
Verreckt mir jetzt mein Fire-HD-Tablet im Flur oben.
Weiß ich gar nicht, woher ich ein neues Dashboard für's...
es für den flur finde spiegel dashboard das muss ein tablet für mit einem
browser drin also das wollen wir nicht haben was haben wir die angebote unter
20 euro mode schuhe computer und software
intelligentes zuhause gibt es ja auch normal baumarkt werkzeug kann man alter
kommen der dark reader der hier umsprang kopfhörer und lautsprecher
haustierbedarf ok tschecho kommen wir kaufen was für tschecho bei the way
leute tschecho geht es ein bisschen besser der blutdruck ist runter gegangen
von tschecho glücklicherweise tschecho geht es offensichtlich merkt das richtig
die meckert schon wieder viel mehr wenn ich wenn ich zu lahm bin irgendwas
rechtzeitig zu machen letzten tage hat die nur in den seilen
gehängt aber jetzt jetzt die kriegt der blutdruck tabletten jetzt tschecho und
der ist jetzt auch wieder ordentlich runter gegangen und jetzt geht sie
deutlich besser
ja ganz kurz ich bin nicht so hundertprozentig daraus schlau geworden
was es ist was ich gesehen habe ist ein dashboard für irgendwelche cloud
anwendung aber das ist es glaube ich nicht so ganz gecheckt habe ich noch
nicht ja die habe ich auch nicht komplett
geguckt nur so ganz kurz rein also ich habe keine ahnung was es eigentlich
kennen die videos aber ich weiß nicht was es ist
vielleicht kannst du mir das in zwei sätzen sagen was es ist ja leider leider
meine alten ließ sich noch flaschen als trinken und ok
Jahrrip anders realized hier jetzt sind wir bei haustierbedarf oder kann es sein
dass man das ende richtig auf auf machen kann
Haustier bedarf komm Tschecho kriegt war das alles klar so alles für haustier das
Das kann die nicht futtern, die braucht Nierennahrung.
Kratzbaum hat sie, juckt sie nicht.
Die kratzt am liebsten an so einem Korb im Wohnzimmer.
Ich meine, Chico denkt sich auch, warum soll ich am Kratzbaum kratzen, wenn ich auch einfach an was anderem kratzen kann.
So super advanced ein Kratzbaum interessiert, würde die weniger interessieren, weil die klettert schon nicht auf dem, was ich gebaut habe.
Die hüpft eigentlich nur auf so ein Brett hoch und chillt dann da ab.
Alles andere interessiert sie nicht.
Ich habe es schon öfters probiert.
So ein ähnliches Teil habe ich zum Transport von Chico.
Moorpilot.
Ist bestimmt auch ein China-Chinesen-Ding, oder?
Wobei ich finde, der Name ist grenzwertig China-Chinesen-Kram.
Es könnte auch nicht China-Chinesen sein.
Das ist ziemlich schlecht freigestellt, die Katze hier, oder?
Ja, ist es China-Chinesen-Zeug oder nicht?
Es sieht jetzt erstmal nicht so aus.
Weil es eine Adresse in den USA hat.
Aber das heißt ja nichts.
Es könnte durchaus irgendein China-Chinesen-Ding sein.
Der Text sieht auch so nach China-Chinesen aus.
Allein schon der Text ist bestrebt, eine bessere Versorgung mit Haustieren zu gewährleisten.
Moment, das ist China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Wir suchen mal Google Maps.
Ja, ist klar.
Das ist eindeutig der Moorpilot.
Und Firmensitz, ja.
So ein kleines Einfamilienhaus mit Garage.
Also, ich vermute mal, es ist eine China-Chinesen-Tasche.
Guck hier, Leute.
Hier ist das Headquarter von Moorpilot.
Apple wurde doch in einer Garage gegründet.
Ja, also in 100 Prozent.
Aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie riecht das so nach China-Chinesen-Kram.
Weil die haben auch, guck mal.
Air Purification.
Fire, so ein Standard-China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Kitchen.
Ice Cube Maker.
Es ergibt eigentlich gar keinen Sinn, äh.
Drop Shipping.
Irgendwas.
Das ist auf jeden Fall China-Chinesen-Zeug, ja.
Aber so ein ähnliches Teil habe ich auch.
Die sind wirklich ganz praktisch.
Okay.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, wollen sie es einfacher machen, wie man Distributed Systems entwickeln kann.
Also, wenn du zum Beispiel eine AP und eine Web-Anwendung hast, musst du nicht mehr die URL angeben, wo das Portal...
...die AP findet, sondern es geht einfach über ein Discoveries von .NET Aspire.
Okay.
Aha.
So richtig kann ich es mir jetzt trotzdem nicht vorstellen.
Muss ich mir das mal angucken.
Also, das ist nix hier.
Nix.
So, was können wir für Chico kaufen?
Katzenbrunnen.
Katzenbrunnen mit Wasserhahn.
Jetzt wird es aber advanced langsam.
Also, Katzenbrunnen habe ich auch einige am Start.
Der Gio...
Giotohun.
Store.
Auch China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Also, Katzenbrunnen habe ich auch ein paar am Start.
Und Chico findet die mega nice.
Also, Chico trinkt...
Also, Chico hat zwei Brunnen, drei Näpfchen rumstehen und sitzt trotzdem den ganzen Tag im Bad und meckert, wenn ich nicht schnell genug reinkomme, um den Wasserhahn anzumachen.
Aber wer eine Katze hat und keinen Katzenbrunnen...
Also, nicht den hier, aber irgendeinen Katzenbrunnen kann ich empfehlen.
Das bringt richtig was und die Katzen trinken dann auch mehr.
Gerade ältere Katzen neigen dazu, zu wenig zu trinken.
Fressnapf, GPS-Tracker.
Haltbarer Hundenapf.
Warum genau braucht man das?
Ja, ist nix dabei für Chico.
Wie gedacht, können wir irgendwas Nices holen für Chico, aber nur Schrott dabei.
Krallenschleife, sowas braucht man nicht.
Wenn die Katze ordentlich die Krallen wetzt, muss man die auch nicht mal schneiden.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Wow-Wow-Angebote.
Massive Wow.
Huge Wow.
Exakt die Lampe.
Die brauch ich, die sieht...
Die sieht so modern aus.
Die sieht aus wie von meiner Oma, nur in billig.
Alter, the fuck?
Retro, hä?
Retro-Lampe.
Sieht wirklich aus wie das, was meine Oma hatte früher.
Nur, dass die von der Oma etwas qualitativ hochwertiger war.
Hast du jetzt zu den Katzen auch einen Hund?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Okay, lass uns mal kurz gucken, ob's irgendwie geschafft ist.
Und hier ist irgendwie ein gescheites Werkzeug.
Reolink-Kameras, mal gucken.
Also davon hab ich ein paar.
Mal gucken, ob irgendwas Spannendes dabei ist, wo ich sage, hey, wenn ich nochmal eine weitere Kamera brauche, dann wird's die.
Also von den Dingern mit Solarpanel, Stromversorgung halte ich nicht viel, weil die kannst du nicht konstant streamen.
Und eine Überwachungskamera, die man nicht konstant streamen kann, ist irgendwie...
etwas useless.
Die ist gut, wenn man die halt einmal am Tag
streamen will, weil einer an der Tür steht oder sowas.
Und deswegen
finde ich das blödsinnig.
Also mit Solar taugt
nix.
Entweder PoE oder Netzteil.
Also Reolink
geht zum größten Teil
ohne Cloud einfach lokal
WLAN, RTSP. Da muss man aber
ein bisschen aufpassen, weil die
haben auch Kameras, die gehen nur mit
Cloud. Und es ist
oftmals nicht direkt auf den ersten Blick zu
sehen,
welcher Typ das jetzt ist.
Das sieht aus wie so eine Weitwinkelkamera,
die links und rechts gucken kann.
Warum hat
die zwei Linsen?
Doch, das ist schon besonders breit.
Und mit Licht ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Ich hab bei mir an der
Haustür so eine hängen.
Die observes normalerweise den Hof.
Aber sobald das
Hoftor aufgeht,
schwenkt die Kamera
automatisch auf die Tür und macht
das Licht an. Da sieht man das Schlüsselloch
besser abends, wenn man im Dunkeln heimkommt.
Argedion
25.
Danke für den Sub.
Exzellent.
Ich muss in das Creator Dashboard
gucken, dass ich nicht mehr was übersehen hab.
Also da ist nix dabei.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Teil, was
irgendwie super Weitwinkel-Dings
hinkriegt.
Nix am Start.
Aber irgendwie ein paar gescheite,
Werkzeug-Sachen.
Die üblichen Bosch Akkuschrauber,
die gibt's immer, jedes Mal.
Man kann das aber auch empfehlen.
Das ist ein echt ganz brauchbares Set.
Und der hier ist auch gut.
Man glaubt gar nicht, was so ein 12 Volt Akkuschrauber
Moment, ist das der mit
Schlagbohrfunktion
oder ohne? Das ist der GSR.
Ich glaub der
GBR hat das. Also der GSR
ist ohne. Sieht man ja auch hier.
Fehlt ja auch.
Fehlt ja auch Bohr.
Zum Bohren hat ein bisschen.
Mehr Abstand.
Ähm.
Ja.
Aber man glaubt gar nicht, was man mit nem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber
alles schrauben kann.
Ich hab damit schon Löcher in meine Hauswand gebohrt.
Mit nem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber.
Mit in, in, in die, in die, in die
stabile Wand außen.
Ich mein natürlich ist ne ordentlich Bohrmaschine besser dafür.
Aber wenn man grad nirgends nix zur Hand hat
und sonst irgendwie erst
ewig weit rumlaufen muss, Kabel legen und so, ist das ganz praktisch.
Also man kann mit so nem 12 Volt Akkuschrauber wirklich nicht viel mehr machen.
Man kann wirklich mehr schrauben und, und bohren, als man eigentlich denkt.
Also du kannst fast alles Hand, Haus, so Haushaltsgängige, übliche machen.
Du hast das in einem chinesischen Handelsregister gefunden?
Excellent.
Ganz ehrlich.
Man sollte den Hersteller nehmen, der ganz gut reinpasst bei sich, je nachdem was man für Akkus hat.
Es macht keinen Sinn.
Man kann alle, man kann alle nehmen.
Es muss halt zum restlichen Ökosystem.
passen.
Falls man noch mehr Geräte mit Akku hat.
Da gibt's doch meine Rauchmelder einfach.
Ja.
Okay, die kann ich tatsächlich empfehlen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie preislich gut, Moment, sind das die, ach, das sind die ohne Funk, ja, Keck, wait, Keck, wait, Keck, wait.
Das ist ja super weird, Champ, guck mal.
Die bieten das Funkmodul für die Rauchmelder an.
Aber in diese Rauchmelder hier,
kann man das Funkmodul,
meines Wissens nach, gar nicht einbauen.
In die klassischen.
Ist das Cheap Bait?
Dass die Leute aus versehen sich irgendwas kaufen, was nicht, was nicht geht?
Du benutzt Parkside.
Parkside ist Lidl, gell?
Forstwirtschaftliche Geräte.
Oh ja.
So ein, so ein, so ein Helm.
Jetzt nix dabei, was mich irgendwie jucken würde?
Nö.
Ein, irgendwie, irgendwie langweilig, oder?
Uhu, jawoll.
Irgendwie.
CNC-Fräsmaschinen, Moment, so Zeug ist doch mega teuer, und wenn es nicht,
okay, und wenn es nicht mega teuer ist, dann taugt es wahrscheinlich nix.
Gen-Mitsu, das ist bestimmt auch China-Chinesen-Zeug, ja?
Weil, ich wüsste nicht, wozu ich eine CNC-Maschine daheim bräuchte.
Aber, aber, ich mein, es gibt bestimmt Leute, die brauchen das.
Und wann will man sich schon mal selbst was gravieren?
Daheim.
Das sieht auf dem Bild dann so cool aus, oder?
Am Ende hast du es irgendwo stehen und benutzt es nie.
So, so, hau.
Auch China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Vago-Klemmen, jawoll.
Bäh.
Das sind aber die Alten, das sind die ganz Alten noch.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es die überhaupt noch gibt.
Gibt, ich dachte, das sind, Chad, kennst du dich damit einer aus?
Das sind doch die Alten, oder?
Die Neuen sind doch viereckig.
Das sind die, nee, das sind auch nicht, das sind die Neuen.
Die Rechten sind die Neuen.
Das sind die Neuen.
Genau, die Neuen sind durchsichtig und haben so ein Klips-Klaps-Dings obendrauf.
Die wollen, die wollen ihre alten Klemmen loswerden, oder?
Hier habe ich mir mal übelst den Finger wehgetan.
Das habe ich tagelang noch gemerkt.
Mit so einer Vago-Klemme.
Also, die Alten, die hatten so einen Feder.
Hier ist quasi so eine, ich weiß nicht, ob da eine Feder wirklich drin ist.
Zumindest, du hast...
Du machst, du klippst, du machst das hoch, hier diesen.
Ja, du machst hier dieses Ding hoch, steckst das Kabel rein, machst das runter.
Und das Problem ist, du hast das Kabel hier reingemacht, hast das Kabel mit dem Finger, ich habe das Kabel reingemacht, also Klemme hoch.
Kabel reingemacht, da habe ich das Kabel festgehalten und dann habe ich die Klemme zugemacht mit dem zweiten Finger.
Und dann hat mir die Klemme übelst auf den Fingernagel gehauen vom Zeigefinger.
Ohne Scheiß, das habe ich Tage danach noch gemerkt.
Also, die haben richtig Zug drauf, Benni.
Die zuglatscht, ne.
Deswegen, ich finde die neuen deutlich angenehmer.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn man diese zwei Dinger, wenn man die zwei...
Plutarchus und dein Nagel...
Nein.
Ne, glaub nicht, dass es Plutarchus war.
Da könnte ich mich dran erinnern noch besser.
Ich finde auch, man sieht hier so richtig, das linke sieht aus wie so ein Prototyp, ja.
Und das rechte sieht halt aus wie was fertig entwickeltes, irgendwie.
Vor allem ist es auch...
Durchsichtig, was enorm praktisch ist, dass du siehst, ob alles ordentlich drin ist bis zum Anschlag.
Und dass auch die Isolierung lang genug ist, weil du sollst...
Man steckt das ja hier so rein.
Ja, das sind noch die einen.
Man muss das ja so reinstecken, dass die Isolierung da reingeht.
Aber die Isolierung darf auch wiederum nicht zu lang sein, dass die Klemme nicht klemmt.
Naja.
Aber Vago-Klemme sind top.
Kann man nix sagen.
Um Kabel miteinander zu verbinden, was einfach hält.
Und wenn man keinen Bock hat, das irgendwie zusammenzulöten und drüber zu ins Vago klemmen, einfach top.
Die Weller-Lötstationen, ne.
Die sehen immer aus wie vor 150 Jahren.
Auch mit so einem super großen, handlichen, unhandlichen Lötkolben dabei.
Zohan 030 Gehörschutz.
Ich dachte, das ist so bunt, das ist bestimmt ein Gaming-Headset mit schlechtem Klang, aber ist es nicht.
Heimwerker.
Oh, nice.
Leute, wollt ihr auch schon immer Heimwerker kaufen?
Ah, sowas.
Sowas gibt's da.
Okay.
Hau mal alles nett.
Weller ist beste.
Ich find meine Air-Salut-Station auch sehr nice.
Mal gucken, vielleicht gibt's die auch mal Black Friday billig.
Ne.
Die ist hier gar nicht drin.
Ah gut, ist aber Black Friday.
Ne, noch nix gefunden.
Wie der Titel sagt.
T-Baited, ja.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, welche ich habe.
Also meine ist nicht blau.
Aber ich glaub, blau sind einfach nur die neuen.
Ich glaub, ich hab ne Nano.
Ich glaub, das ist meine.
Ja, ja, das ist meine. Relativ sicher, ja, die da.
Also das ist echt mal ein Kauf, der sich gelohnt hat.
Ich hab mir damals auch gedacht, Max, warum kaufst du dir für über 200 Euro ne Lötstation?
Aber ist doch nicht so.
Das ist doch gerade als Deal.
Und, ja, man kann dafür noch viel mehr ausgeben.
Aber das ist wirklich ein Ding, das hat sich im Nachhinein echt gelohnt.
Also was ich übrigens noch nie gemacht habe, ist, den Micro-SD-Karten-Slot an meiner Lötstation verwendet.
Ich hab auch bis heute nicht wirklich gecheckt, wofür das da ist.
Da kann man, glaub ich, irgendwelche Custom-Heizstufen einstellen und sowas.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Aber ansonsten, das hat sich echt gelohnt.
Ich find das sehr angenehm, damit zu arbeiten.
Vor allem, weil der Lötkolben schön handlich ist.
Das ist nicht so ein fetter, guck mal, man sieht's hier.
Das ist nicht so ein fetter, so ein fetter, unhandlicher...
Das ist quasi wie so ein kleiner Stift.
Relativ leicht.
Kann die Spitze tauschen.
Und das Kabel ist sehr elastisch.
Elastisch.
Kann das auch wirklich in ganz engen, engen Schleifen liegen.
Also, das hat sich echt gelohnt.
Ist zwar nicht so billig, aber die hat sich gelohnt.
Also damit macht das...
Also seit ich die hab, die hab ich ja auch schon ein paar Jahre jetzt, seitdem, immer wenn es was zu löten gibt, wird gelötet.
Weil ich Bock drauf hab, das Ding zu benutzen.
Wie heißt die kleine Marke, wo jeder Handwerk...
Ja, genau, genau, die.
Das sind die, die das ein bisschen, die so Handwerkerbekleidung irgendwie so ein bisschen zur Mode gemacht haben.
Was ist das?
Boah, Alter, was ist das für ein...
Das ist, das ist Ultra-China-Chinesen-Ding, oder?
Hyper-China-Chinesen-Ding.
Das, das, das schreit schon China-Chinesen-Ding.
Ich mein, du kriegst hier...
Ne Station, also erst mal der Name...
Yihua!
Da weißt du schon Bescheid, ja.
Aber, ich mein, du kriegst...
Ne Lötstation mit...
Nicht so Hightech aus...
Ne Lötkolben dabei.
Heißluft.
Plus Zubehör.
Und noch die unterschiedlichsten Spitzen.
Und noch, und noch ne, ne...
So ne, so ne...
Unterdruck-Dings, Abdings-Pumpel, Lötzinn.
Aufsätze für den Föhn.
Und irgendeine billige Pinzette.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das ist qualitativ fragwürdig.
Die kannst du direkt im Handel mit dem Feuermelder kaufen, ja.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, man tut diesem China-Zeug ja oftmals auch Unrecht.
Die, ähm, sind oftmals auch besser, als man denkt.
Man wird, also ich wurde auch schon von China-Zeug, also wirklich oft positiv überrascht.
Ähm...
Aber in dem Fall, ich weiß nicht genau.
Was, drei in ein Station?
Moment, was ist da als drittes noch dabei?
Moment, das ist doch ein...
Ist das...
Ist das noch ein Multimeter, oder was?
Oder was soll das sein?
Channel 1, 2, ist das irgendein...
Oszilloskop, oder was?
Ach ne, das ist ein Netzteil.
Das ist ein Netzteil.
Wollte grad sagen, dass er...
Ja, okay.
Jetzt, okay.
Ich finde, das macht irgendwie sogar noch Sinn.
An so nem, an so nem Teil, ja.
Und, und...
Es ist auch nicht unsicher, weil...
Also, was heißt unsicher?
Mag es sein?
Aber du lässt sowas ja nie unbeaufsichtigt.
Also, das kann man sich...
Kann man sich überlegen.
Kein Titel.
Alles okay.
Das Gerät funktioniert.
Ist immer vor dem Chef auf der Arbeit.
Meint ihr, das sind echte Käufe oder Fake-Bewertung?
Okay, verifizierter Kauf.
Wobei, das ja auch...
Naja.
Der Gerät.
Das ist...
Das ist eindeutig ne Fünf-Sterne-Bewertung, oder?
Alles okay.
Das Gerät funktioniert.
Wobei, die Bewertung ist schon so blöd.
Die ist wahrscheinlich sogar echt.
Um jetzt hier mal ein bisschen besseren Eindruck zu bekommen,
lasst uns mal die ein und zwei...
Drei Sterne.
Und jetzt bitte, bitte das Ganze noch auf...
Auf Deutsch.
Wie kann man das irgendwie nach Deutsch...
Ins Deutsche übersetzen?
Kann man vielleicht nicht sortieren nur nach Deutsch?
Ich glaub, das macht er automatisch, ja.
Not working.
Hot air gun, the surrounding plastic starting to melt.
Das sieht schon eher nach China-Chinesen aus.
Das sollte nicht so sein, ne?
Immer ganz davon abgesehen, ich will mir das eh nicht kaufen.
Ich meine, er hat mich jetzt immer interessiert, ob da irgendwie ein bisschen...
Pretty good.
Naja.
Es gibt schon enorm viel Schrott jedes Mal beim Prime Day, oder?
Ich würde sagen, 99% ist Schrott.
Beliebte Angebote.
Okay, was kaufen die Leute denn so bei Amazon?
Ah, okay, die kaufen 304 Seiten Sachen.
Warum kann man nicht auf 304 klicken, Amazon?
Warum geht das nicht?
Warum kann ich nicht einfach auf 304 gehen?
Warum ist die Amazon-Webseite so kacke?
Ich seh auch nix.
Ich find das...
Kleine Indie-Company, die können sich nicht leisten.
Ja, verstehe.
Deswegen müsst ihr Prime subben, dass der CEO demnächst wieder ins Weltall fliegen kann.
Okay.
Ja, ich glaube, das kannst du knicken.
Ich bin jedes Jahr weniger gehypt von dem Zeug.
Es gibt einfach nur unglaublich viel und davon unglaublich viel Schrott.
Und ab und zu mal was ganz Brauchbares, was man dann auch nur kauft, weil es mal was ganz Brauchbares ist, was man gar nicht braucht.
Das ist genauso wie so ein Ding, ne?
So irgendwelche Ladegeräte und so und Powerbanks.
Kann man immer mal sich gönnen.
Aber wirklich brauchen?
Man hat ja eigentlich das meiste schon.
Man muss wissen, was man will.
Wenn man weiß, was man will, ist das wahrscheinlich nicht im Angebot.
Anker.
Anker ist übrigens auch China-Chinesen-Kram.
Auch wenn der Name so...
So norddeutsch irgendwie klingt, so...
Irgendwie so schiffmäßig, so geankert.
Das ist aber auch China-Chinesen-Kram.
Die sind nicht schlecht.
Die machen auch eigene Sachen.
Die sind nicht der 500...
China-Chinesen-Reseller.
Von Anker habe ich auch ein paar Sachen, ja?
Ich glaube diesen...
Ohne Mist, Leute.
Diesen USB-Hub, den hatte doch jeder schon mal, oder?
Ich kenne...
Okay.
Ist jetzt übertrieben, wenn ich sage, ich kenne bestimmt 50 Leute, die diesen USB-Hub haben.
Weil es ist gelogen, wenn ich sage, dass ich 50 Leute so gut kenne, dass sie mir ihren USB-Hub zeigen würden daheim oder so.
Aber den hat doch gefühlt jeder, oder?
Jeder hat diesen USB-Hub, Mann.
Oder schon mal gehabt.
Oder gerade im Einsatz.
Ich habe auch hier.
Hey, ein Link bei mir mitten auf dem Schreibtisch gerade.
So sieht es aus, ja.
USB-Hubs sind schon sehr private Angelegenheit.
Chat, es gibt nichts.
Können wir vergessen.
Können wir vergessen, Mann.
Alter, zu damit.
Zeig mal deinen USB-Hub.
Was beim Media...
Moment, Media Markt...
Alter, es haben ja alle welche, ne?
Media Markt Slime.
Okay, da weißt du wenigstens, was ich will.
Media Markt Black Friday.
Let's go, Black Friday Week.
Audio.
Okay, da könnt vielleicht was...
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin sehr Kopfhörer- und Headset-affin.
Aber vor allem Kopfhörer.
Habe ich auch seit Jahren schon mehr als notwendig.
Darf man hier Empfehlungswünsche?
Klar, was denn?
Du hast echt diesen USB-Hub von Hanke...
Ja, ich sage, jeder hatte den schon mal oder hat den gerade.
Unsere Heiner als Kopfhörer.
Da ist jetzt nichts dabei, was mich irgendwie überzeugt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ein Noise-Canceling, schön und gut, aber...
Da reicht einer.
Äh, nix bei.
Gut, wenn man die Leute belästigen möchte im Zug, so ist es bestimmt nice.
Ja, Fahrradfahren damit würde ich auch nicht.
Aber im Zug und so ist es sehr praktisch, manchmal ein Noise-Canceling.
Kopfhörer zu haben.
Nee, gerade nicht.
Mein Fahrrad ist ja nicht fahrtauglich gerade.
Seit ein paar Wochen, als mich die eine über den Haufen gefahren hat.
Die Versicherung hat übrigens immer noch nicht bezahlt.
Oder ist das der Normalpreis?
Ich würde sagen, das ist ziemlich der normale Preis.
Zumindest wie es bei ursprünglich war.
UVP 130.
Im Leben nicht.
Was hat sich Amazon denn da ausgedacht?
Doch.
Sonntag erst wieder 10 Kilometer gerannt.
Und ich hab das kaputte Fahrrad bei mir auf dem Smart-Trainer stehen.
Und radel da ab und zu mal so 45 Minuten bis eine Stunde mit Swift.
Oder über Swift.
Ich swifte, wie manche sagen.
Da merke ich erstmal im Vergleich zu anderen, wie schlecht ich eigentlich beim Fahrradfahren bin.
Schon mal Halbmarathon gelaufen?
Nee.
Aber nachdem ich 10 Kilometer...
...schaffe, relativ problemlos, gehe ich da mal von aus, 20 würde ich auch noch schaffen.
Mehr nicht, weil vielleicht gar nicht so sehr von, weil ich überhaupt nicht mehr...
Also ich müsste auf jeden Fall was essen und trinken dabei.
Sondern weil mir die Beine und Gelenke wehtun wahrscheinlich.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das größte Problem dabei.
Aber 20 sollte ich schaffen.
Mein knapp 11 bin ich ja schon gerannt.
Die 9, oh betruff, die würde ich auch noch hinkriegen.
Aber dann reicht es auch echt.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich gut geworden mittlerweile.
Also wir haben ja am Anfang nach 5, 6 Kilometer die nächsten 2, 3 Tage so die Waden und vor allem das Schienbein wehgetan,
dass ich eigentlich schon gar keinen Bock mehr hatte, dann weiter zu rennen.
Und das ist mittlerweile wirklich viel besser geworden.
Ich bin jetzt am Sonntag 10,1 oder so gerannt.
Also ein bisschen knapp über 10 Kilometer gerannt.
Und heute ist Montagabend und mir tut nichts mehr weh.
Nö, mach ich nicht.
Das hab ich auch gedacht.
Hättest du mir das mal vor einem halben Jahr erzählt, dass ich mal 10 Kilometer am Stück renne, 6 Minuten 22 pro Kilometer,
dann hätte ich gedacht, willst du mich verarschen?
Im Leben, warum sollte ich sowas...
Im Leben mach ich das nicht.
Warum sollte ich sowas...
Warum sollte ich sowas machen?
Ne, und ich glaube, die aktuellen lassen sich auch nicht mal richtig routen.
Bin ich mir aber bei Sticks nicht sicher.
Aber Tablets auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ah, das wird auch wieder besser.
Dann ist dein Fahrrad wahrscheinlich nicht richtig eingestellt.
Gerade je nachdem, was du für einen Lenkertyp hast und wenn du die Hände zu sehr abknickst.
Ich hatte übrigens das gleiche.
Also nicht Handgelenke.
Ich hatte übelst Druck immer auf den Händen.
Einfach weil ich es nicht gewöhnt habe.
Und das Ding ist halt, was ich beim Fahrradfahren gemerkt habe,
umso mehr man reintritt, ich weiß nicht, wie man es anders nennen soll,
umso mehr Power man in die Pedale kriegt dauerhaft,
umso mehr entlastet das auch die Hände,
weil man eben nicht mehr sich so viel aufstützt,
weil halt die Beine einen so ein bisschen dann hochheben so vorne,
weil man halt ordentlich reintritt.
Also umso besser man reintritt, umso besser für die Hände.
Also umso mehr man reintritt, umso besser für die Hände.
Und was bei mir...
Und man kommt schneller ans Ziel.
Und was bei mir auch enorm geholfen hat, sind Handschuhe.
Gerade die ersten paar Runden haben mir übelst die Hände wehgetan
und die Handflächen danach auch so von den Erschütterungen am Lenker und sowas.
Dann habe ich mir so ein Pack Handschuhe mit ein bisschen so Gel drin,
Geleinlagen gekauft, wo so Gel drin ist unten an den Druckpunkten.
Und seitdem ist es viel, viel besser.
Und bei Handgelenken muss man gucken, dass man es nicht zu stark ab- und anwinkelt,
je nachdem, wie man den Lenker hat.
Also es ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Chat gilt 22.06.
Ich muss morgen früh aufstehen nach Frankfurt.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Heute war mit Einkauf ja nicht so viel,
aber im Prinzip, wie der Streamtitel gesagt hat,
wieder nur Mist bei Black Friday.
Ich hätte echt Bock, mir endlich ein neues Fahrrad zu kaufen.
Lass doch mal gerade kurz gucken, bevor ich abhaue.
Ob welche lieferbar sind.
Also das ist mein aktuelles Fahrrad.
Am liebsten hätte ich eine 1x12.
Die 2, aber das gibt es nicht.
Shimano hat keinen Bock.
Okay, ist meiner Größe nicht.
Sind meine auch nicht in meiner Größe, ja.
F.
Ja, die sind preis-leistungsmäßig gut.
Das stimmt.
Deswegen werde ich mir auch wieder eins kaufen.
Ah ja.
Mal warten.
Wenn ich noch ein bisschen warte, gibt es vielleicht 1x12 Di2.
Weil die mechanische Variante 1x12 gibt es ja schon.
Vielleicht gibt es dann bald auch die elektronische Schaltungsvariante
irgendwann nächstes Jahr.
Okay, Chat, jetzt gehe ich aber echt pennen.
Bis dann, wir sehen uns.
Mach's gut.
See you.